diese doku also exklusiv auf bild.de am
mir nun zugeschaltet mein kollege peter
thiede
denn du begleitet den prozess jetzt für
uns der heute beginnt wie genau soll
diese ablaufen was ist bereits bekannt
also heute hat der prozess gestartet
gegen den angeklagten gegen einen
russischen staatsbürger darunter zwei
namen auftritt einmal den alias-namen
sockel auf und ansonsten heißt im
wirklichen leben quasi kopf der hat hier
genau dort wo ich stehe
im kleinen tiergarten in berlin unter
diesem baum hat der langgasse willi
umgebracht er ist hat sich von hinten
genähert hat ihm zunächst vom fahrrad
aus mit einer glocke 26 jahr zwölf
schuss ein schuss von der seite in den
oberkörper gegeben und dann zwei schüsse
in den kopf
der notarzt konnte nur noch den tod
feststellen noch heute ist hier direkt
unter mir reste von dieser blut lage
gemacht vom 23 08 2009 10 noch immer zu
sehen und 600 meter von mir entfernt ist
das kriminalgericht moabit wo jetzt auch
der wo der prozess stattfindet heute war
die verlesung der anklageschrift und da
und da wird es spannend weil die anklage
geht fest davon aus dass der täter im
auftrag der russischen des russischen
staates hier gehandelt hat dass ein
auftragskiller des kremls war der hier
in berlin in sichtweite fast das
kanzleramt das gemordet hat im auftrag
des russischen staates ist dieser
prozess ist natürlich die
strafrechtliche seite dieses mordes
trotzdem es ist ein politischer mord
gewesen was auch gerade gesagt in der
anklage wird es noch einmal festgehalten
wie sieht da bisher die aufarbeitung
dieses falls haus da sind die deutschen
behörden hat die einzigen die die da
ermitteln die auch ermitteln können und
sie können auf eine ist nicht zählen
nämlich auf dem mit hilfe russischer
staatlicher stellen was bekannt ist ist
ja dass der mutmaßliche täter muss man
ja noch sagen jetzt fast aufgehört hatte
er wird schon aber der angeklagte ist
mit gefälschten pässen eingereist das
visum wurde auf eine firma ausgestellt
die die eigentlich nur als faxgerät
existiert hat aber in den räumen und in
räumlichkeiten des militärischen
nachrichtendienstes russlands nämlich
das gu residiert haben soll
daraufhin hat auf diese adresse und auf
eine einladung hat in frankreich ein
visum ausgestellt dann ist er nach paris
gereist von paris ist er dann nach
warschau gereist und dann hatte in
berlin
die tat vollbracht und die tat kann er
nicht allein verbracht haben sowohl nach
einschätzung der general die
generalbundesanwaltschaft die hier die
anklage führt als auch nach
geheimdienstexperten mit denen wir nur
selbst gesprochen haben denn der täter
muss gewusst haben dass das opfer das
beschädigen kann
jeden freitag zu einer bestimmten
uhrzeit durch diesen kleinen park hier
geht dass er sich hier manchmal auf eine
bank gesetzt und dann losgeht zum
freitagsgebet und genau zu diesem
zeitpunkt kommt jemand der also aus
moskau über paris und über warschau
gerade erst hier angekommen ist er hat
eine waffe er hat ein fahrrad und nicht
unweit von diesem tatort stand dennoch
ein elektro roller für ihn bereit das
alles muss vorbereitet worden sein
irgendjemand ein team muss vorher das
opfer ausgespäht haben und dann muss es
ein zweites team noch gegeben haben weil
solche killer auftragskiller lässt kein
lässt keine diktatur der welt einfach so
gewähren oder die auch die werden
beobachtet für den fall dass sie sich
offenbaren dass sie zu einer
polizeistation rennen oder fehler machen
also zwei teams man geht fest davon aus
dass das teams waren 11 aus russland
selber oder aus einem aus einem anderen
europäischen land russische staatsbürger
russische staatsdiener und einen team
das hier eng angebunden ist an die
deutsche botschaft an die russische
botschaft in deutschland so ein
verbrechen kann keiner allein beginn mit
ausspielen und alle möglichen also da
ein tourist der mit einer waffe hier
quer durch europa reist und dann in
berlin beim intel p55 am hellichten tag
um sich ballert das kann nicht
funktionieren
das ist so tat selber hat bekannt und
man muss auch dazu sagen dass das opfer
eigentlich zweimal gestorben ist hier
erschossen worden und dann direkt danach
setzt ja die russische staatspropaganda
ein mann hat ihn zu einem islamisten
erklärte er nicht wahr sondern er hat
für westliche geheimdienste und führen
die augen geheimdienst aktiv gearbeitet
nach dem was wir wissen hat er aktiv
anschläge verhindert er hat islamisten
die nach die nach europa sollten
enttarnt und gemeldet und er war unter
anderem für einen amerikanischen
geheimdienst auch in der ukraine tätig
weil russland dort islamisten und vor
allem tschetschenen eingesetzt hat im
krieg gegen die ukraine
und da war eine derjenigen die das mit
untersucht haben wie das aufgeklärt
haben mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht
abonnieren